The Joe Rogan experience thing.
You want to get really nuts? Yes.
It's time to leave. Time to
leave. What? This planet. Oh boy.
Listen, we can leave this plant. I've
got something right here. No, no, no.
Take you to another planet right
now. He's joking. Federal agents. Ah,
let me, let me give you my
argument. Where are we going? Well,
we don't know that we can leave
this planet. I love this planet.
I love this plant. I have a good time
here. This is my favorite planet.
Mine too. I know. But
here's the real reason that
we started a clock around 1953,
which is when we had the explosion at
bikini and the first hydrogen bomb.
And um, when we figured
out the double helix,
and I call this the twin nuclei
problem, and it began in 1953, 1953,
we started a clock. It was also
the height of the McCarthy era.
We do not have the wisdom
to be able to fuse nuclei.
We don't have the wisdom to be
able to investigate the cell.
It's too much power.
Okay.
So our wisdom may have increased
slightly. Maybe it didn't,
I don't know that our power is now godly.
So our biological intelligence,
what our minds are capable of has not it,
it's been surpassed by our intellectual
achievements in terms of our,
our, our technological innovation,
these things which while complicated,
um,
succumb to our intellects, right? Right.
Like they're much simpler
than we ever imagined.
To be able to create something
that normally happens in
the sun on an Island in
the Pacific or to be able to rewrite
a cell the way Craig Venter did,
you know, synthetic biology, we are now
gods, but for the wisdom,
and that's a great quote. We are now gods,
but for the wisdom should be like
meme pictures. You can picture.
You are now God, let's keep that
going to the ones right now I know.
Let's not focus. Okay. Sorry. Okay.
So that started this clock and the world's
most serious human beings should be
working on the twin nuclei problem.
What do we do with new godlike
powers given our history of conflict,
our history of envy, our
history of madness, right?
Because we succumb
regularly. We are, you know,
I was born 20 years after the end of
world war II and we all know what really
happened there. I mean, we're nuts.
We're absolutely not capable of
this level of responsibility.
And so the question that we have is,
do we believe that we have a longterm
solution in terms of increasing our
wisdom? We should definitely try it.
Everybody believes that should
work on that problem. But,
um, if we don't think that we
have the wisdom to live like this,
we don't know how much time we have
left, but it's probably not hundreds.
It's probably maybe a few hundred years
tops because sooner or later you're
going to have Putin like
Trump, like people. I mean,
I'm sorry. I would have a very deep
antipathy towards Donald Trump. Um,
he's not temperamentally fit to have the
secrets of theoretical physics at his
fingertips. It just isn't.
And it's imperative to me that he not be
elected in 2020 and that the democratic
party wake up and get rid of its crazy
fringe so that we can buy some time.
And it's nice if Elon
thinks we can go to Mars,
maybe that will allow a small number of
us to diversify in case we do something
really dumbed at the planet.
But if human beings are to continue
and we are to continue evolving,
we need to spread out and there are
three rocks that are inhabitable.
There's the earth, there's
the moon, and there's Mars.
The moon has nothing in there. Mars is
pretty uninteresting to be in blunt.
I know that it's beautiful that we send
back these pictures and we've got this
one gorgeous planet that we are
clearly not smart enough to Stuart.
We're still having idiotic
climate change debates.
I mean even if even if climate science
is somewhat junk of [inaudible],
we should still be taking climate super
seriously because we don't know what
we're doing.
It's such a complicated nonlinear system
and we're not even capable of focusing.
You know,
we're like two seconds later I'll be
watching the Kardashians for sure.
So what is the answer?
Well, in my opinion,
we got to increase the number of
possible places we can go beyond three
to say nothing of space stations.
Because that's not realistic. Now,
none of these things make sense.
So the first place that you have to get
to is we're really deeply screwed and
not because of apocalyptic cult,
like reasons just because of science,
just because of 1953.
So the only opportunity is if we can break
the Einsteinian speed limit so far as
I know, or we can upload into Silicon
or we can reboot from tardigrades.
Like none of these answers are good.
So
what I've been toying
with since I was 19 was
what is the theory beyond Einstein?
And that's the thing that I've been
most uncomfortable talking about. Um,
although I've been talking about it more.
I gave these lectures in 2013 and in may
of 2013 in Oxford and I was appalled by
the way in which the world's
physics community responded. I mean,
I was very scared. I'm
not a physicist. Um,
I don't claim to be, but I,
I felt like I tried to present what I
hoped was a path forward given that the
field was completely
stalled out. And this is it.
Physics and biology let us
into the Valley of death
and it's now time to try to get
out and [inaudible] go ahead.
No, please pick you up.
So what is my responsibility
in terms of the portal?
Um,
what I'm going to try to do with this
podcast is gained the courage to share
whatever ideas I've had, um,
about breaking the speed limit
in the form of,
I don't think I have the wisdom
to figure out what it means,
but at least I have a hope of trying to
write the fundamental rules to figure
out our source code. And that
was that, that was the plan,
which is what is this place? What
is the source code for reality.
Now, what was the response?
Did the physics to the physicists from
the physicist that you found Pauling?
Well, there were two articles
that appeared in the guardian,
a newspaper or website that, um,
talked breathlessly about what I had
done or what I might have done to call
attention to the lectures
that I was giving.
So this is where the special somone
lectures by Richard Dawkins successor,
Marcus de Soto,
who is a colleague of mine from way
back who found me in New York city,
I think in 2011 2012 or
something like that, working on
this theory, I called geometric unity
and I was very uncomfortable.
I hadn't really told anybody that I was
working on this theory for all these
years because it's a crazy, you know,
there's certain stories that
you find in theoretical physics,
which is kind of the precursor
to madness where you know,
somebody thinks that they've solved, uh,
some big problem and they're
working in secret, you know,
the sort of what happened with Andrew
Weil's and Fermat's last theorem,
which was a really interesting story
because his first proof of Fermat's last
theorem w I think was unfixable.
So he announced a proof that he had
solved like this most famous problem in
mathematics and he didn't have it proof.
And then bizarrely he was under such
pressure that he found another proof and
actually pulled it off. So it's
like, you know, hats off to him.
It's one of the crazy story,
but he was working in secret for seven
years and nobody knew what he was doing.
So sometimes these stories work out.
But he was a professor at Princeton and
very highly regarded and he had sort of
husband seven years worth of work to
pretend that he was releasing papers when
he was actually secretly doing this thing
that would have made him a mad man in
some sense.
And so this is what I was trying to
do is I was not able to work on these
issues, uh,
in the string theory community because
the strength theory community was
possessed of this belief that they
had found the answer back in the 80s.
In 1984 they had what they
thought was a revolution.
And the math community
doesn't think in these terms.
Like both of these are very conservative
communities historically and very
focused on following the leadership
of the top people unless there's a
revolution.
And so I started working on a different
idea to unify the two branches of
physics that appear to be in compatible.
That was different than the string
theory idea in different than the loop
quantum gravity idea or any of the hazard.
Then your main motivation was to do this,
to try to figure out a more advanced
version of space travel. Well,
it wasn't space travel. It was,
we need the source code like it's,
it might be safer to go
further once you've unlocked,
once you've unlocked nuclear fusion,
you're pretty much just as
screwed as you need to be.
So then the issue is, okay,
we know that we're pretty,
I'm pretty sure that Einstein's theory
is not final because you get these
singularities, which I don't
associate with ultimate equations.
So the black hole singularity called
the Schwartz Chilson singularity,
or the initial singularity that we
associate with the big bang, um,
and like the Friedman Robertson Walker
space times are signs to me that these
equations are incomplete.
But the big problem with Einstein is
that Einstein's work was so fundamental
that it's like you can't get in
under the ground floor of Einstein.
You begin a physics seminar and you're
already immediately in his world you say,
let X be a spacetime manifold.
Boom, you're already in relativity.
So it's almost impossible to figure out
a way to get in at a deeper level of
physics than Einstein's theory.
And we know that we have to recover
Einstein's theory because that's been
proven, uh, you know, to work
in all sorts of situations.
Then the same thing with quantum field
through, which is why I talked about,
you know, the anomalous
magnetic moment of the electron.
So my idea was that only since the 1970s
have we known that particle theory was
based on geometry. We knew that
Einstein's theory, I think,
use geometry to develop his theory was
the language of relativity called Romani
and geometry.
But many years later we found out that
bores sort of quantum and plunks quantum
in ninth plan's upon him as well, was
based on a different geometry of this Chi.
Charles Eris monk was an Alsatian geometer
who had worked with carton and that
geometry was figured out at Stony
Brook in New York by Jim Simons,
who became the world's greatest
hedge fund manager and CN yang,
who's arguably number one or number two
greatest living theoretical physicists.
He's now in his nineties.
And they figured out that the secret
language of particle theory was also
geometry, but a different geometry.
And so geometric unity is simply the idea
that it's not a fight between Einstein
and Bohr. It's the two parents
remonde on whose work, uh,
Einstein based a relativity and Charles
Eris man with this gauge theoretic stuff
that we did in the time before this, uh,
which in fact empowers a particle theory.
And so when do those two geometries unify
two different geometric theories and,
well, I've found that in general, they
don't unify in a way that you want.
You don't have the ability
to do Einsteinian tensor
analysis where you compress
something called the remonde curvature
tensor and the gauge stuff where you do
this gauge symmetry that we were talking
about because gauge symmetry ruins the
ability to compress the Einstein
tensor. Nevermind what that means.
But in one or two rare circumstances,
you can actually combine
the two geometries. And
that's where I think we are.
And so partially what the part purpose
of the portal podcast is, is to use,
um, you know, I'll just sort of
tear the mask off a little bit.
We've been talking about lots of
interesting things about social justice,
about um, mathematics,
about wonder about psychedelics and
trying to be decent human beings to each
other and to set an example.
And I think it's been partially a
success and partially a failure.
But what I'm trying to do is to gain the
courage to talk about what these ideas
are. And the worst comes to worst is,
is that I wasted a lot of my life on a
crazy theory that turned out not to be
true. What was the response though?
Like how did the physicist
react and what was, what was
disappointing about it?
So the articles in gendered
a, an immune reaction.
Immune. Yeah, it's an
immune response. Okay, okay.
So somebody giving a lecture and now
how many times have we heard before the
next Einstein, yada, yada, yada,
yada. And I totally understand this.
That's a reasonable reaction. Like
Sean Carroll had this reaction.
He referred to me as a backyard.
Einstein and his wife him twice
today. Yeah. He's on my mind.
And his wife, uh,
wrote this amazing article in scientific
American called dear guardian,
you've been played now
she's not a physicist,
but she has access to Sean's
brain and she writes on physics.
And then there was this whole thing
where the new scientist said, okay,
this guy claimed to give this
lecture in the physics department,
but he hasn't written a paper and
he didn't tell the physicists.
So it was a sneak attack. Well,
of course that wasn't true there.
There was announcement of the talk. Um,
I stayed in England and I
give the talk once more, uh,
and then a final time a week
later. And by that point,
all sorts of people from Cambridge
and Oxford came to the tacos.
It was a worldwide topic of
discussion. What the hell is going on?
And I gave a two hour
talk. Consider that nobody,
nobody outside of theoretical physics
gives talks on physics, isn't it?
It's like North Korea. They
don't get many visitors. Right.
To the extent that they get visitors,
they do get visitors from mathematics.
But in general,
mathematicians don't take an
interest in the real physical world.
And to be blunt about it,
I don't think that the string theorists
are very focused on the real physical
world either. They'd been playing
with toy models for you know,
nearly 40 years.
So a lot of it was playing
out in the press. Um,
and the new scientists had to retract.
They said no, what we wrote wasn't true.
They did publicize the
talk and then there was uh,
an article he sent a reporter to the final
talk that I gave and the reporter did
not know any physics.
So I spent the morning with this person
teaching him what the Dereck equation
was like. A very fundamental thing.
And the question came up
in the talk about is your,
is your model anomaly
free? And my model is,
has a property called
[inaudible] [inaudible],
which is the difference
between S left, right?
Asymmetric models are called
chiral and left, right?
Symmetric models are called a non chiral.
So my model is non chiral,
but the chiral nature of the universe
is supposed to emerge from it.
And I was asked questions that didn't
seem to make sense, which is you,
you can't have a chiral
anomaly and a non chiral model.
And the person that the reporter picked
up on this and didn't really get it.
So there was like a flurry
of activity with a big WTF.
And if you ask me, by the time
I gave the second lecture,
people weren't laughing. Um,
it was a serious lecture.
People heard that it was
in an, it was in the light.
It wasn't like somebody come up with
their own language in their own, um,
you know, written in crayon in
some indecipherable thing. It was,
it was written in the normal language,
but I hadn't written a paper.
And papers are very much the
stock and trade of that community.
So I would say that the, the
community settled on a rubric,
which is paper or it didn't happen.
In other words, put up or shut up,
give us a paper. Oh, I
had written something. Um,
but because my trajectory through this,
through math and physics was very unusual.
I have a very low trust of the
academic community. I support them.
As you can tell, you know,
I'm extolling the virtues of science,
but I was subjected to a situation
in graduate school where I had a,
I'm probably the only person you've ever
met with a PhD who was not allowed to
attend his own thesis
defense. Why is that?
I don't know. What was
your thesis? It was on, um,
the self dual equations not being as
peculiar to dimension four as was claimed.
But
I had a situation in which
the thesis when I had,
when I had entered grad school was
something that you would present to the
world. And by the time I was, uh,
trying to leave,
it was a closed door affair where the
department would appoint the person for
you. And I was in the unusual position
of not having a thesis advisor.
So there's some very fraught
story. One thing you'll find is,
is that graduate school for some subclass
of people becomes an extremely fraught
experience where the
power of a department,
not to grant you a degree or not to
help you get a job or to expel you,
um, becomes very contentious.
Right? And that was the situation.
So I got into a very contentious situation
that there was no explanation of why
it was so contentious. We can talk
about it on, on another podcast, but,
um, I was in a very low
trust situation with, um,
with Harvard and with
the standard community.
And so when work that I had done
that was rejected for my thesis,
uh, was discovered by others in 1994, um,
and revolutionized
topological gauge theory,
I became very sort of sullen and angry
and withdrawn because my department knew
that I had put forward the same
equations that became revolutionary in
mathematical gauge theory. Did
you revisit it with them? Um,
there was a seminar where a guy
named David [inaudible], uh,
Y very much admire the person
who had been my advisor.
I don't want to name names, had, uh,
given a seminar saying all of gauge
theory has been revolutionized.
Old Gates' theory is dead. Then
there is a new gauge theory and
um,
David caused on who I will name,
uh, [inaudible]
said I was in the back center row.
I think I was picking my nose
actually. And, um, he said,
didn't we have a student who told
us to look at these equations?
And suddenly the whole room
turned around and looked at me.
I think this is in room five Oh
seven of the Harvard science center.
And it's just like, you
know, try to imagine you're,
you're an anonymous person in a lecture
and suddenly everyone is staring at you
in your fingers in your nose. And, um,
that was the moment.
And I, and I think I mumbled
something, um, just to get out of it.
But I was angry. I was angry that
they'd taken away my, I would, you know,
better, better not to give me
a PhD better just to say, look,
we're going to go short. You
screw off, you don't get a PhD.
And then if I end up doing
something, screw you. You know,
that would have been a
better outcome. So instead,
I got a PhD through a very torturous
situation and I came to give up on
academics. I don't think that they're
a fair system. I don't think that, uh,
it's open-minded.
I don't think that they welcome all
sorts of different belief structures,
um, which are capable of producing
innovations. So, you know, from my money,
I've been very vocal about this.
I've written articles and edged title
work and I've said theoretical physics has
stalled and you've been claiming
that you're going to ship strength,
strength theory, and since
1984 will, where is it?
And it's always, you
know, and years away. Now,
what was the premise of Sean Carroll's
wife's article that they got played?
Well, Jamie, can you bring it up?
I had broken the rules. The rules. Yeah.
You're supposed to submit a paper.
The paper is supposed to be reviewed.
It's supposed to appear in a journal.
You're not supposed to be
doing this from mathematics.
You don't have training as
a physicist. This is a hoax,
but it's on a hose. Whoa. I don't know.
I mean, if it is a hoax, it's on me.
Clearly not a hoax. You're not
hoaxing anyone. I'm not trying to,
I don't understand that well,
because the actual attack. Okay.
Imagine that you're the, you're
the Princeton physics department.
You probably have a cork board on the
wall called the crank, the crank board,
and every week somebody
writes to you and says,
I figured out puppy perpetual motion.
I have a laser transport device.
Right? And so everybody is
concerned and frightened that their,
their time is going to be
wasted right by lunatics.
Now I both fit the lunatic profile and
don't fit the lunatic profile on the
lunatic side. I'm outside of
the system, haven't kept up.
I not particularly
mathematically minded. I mean,
in fact I'm sort of a B math student
from high school, so it's kind of,
I'm the only person I know with my
profile with a PhD in math and on the non
lunatic side. I mean, look,
you've been listening to my crazy ideas
for a while and they're all over the
world. I have lots of heterodox
ideas. I don't think that I,
that they're taken as being insane.
And I don't think this is insane.
It's been looked at by enough people to
say we will until you actually write it
down very cleanly. And clearly we
can't fully evaluate, but it's a,
it's a gamble. And the worst
thing that can happen is,
is that I have something that looks like
a final theory that turns out not to
be, are you gonna write it out?
It's already mostly written up.
I'm in a different phase. I felt
that I got rolled in an alley.
So here's, here's the big,
here's the big reveal. Okay.
It's gonna be a lot harder to
roll me. I can roll myself.
I can screw this thing
up just fine by myself.
But the opportunity to take me into a
quiet corner and make something disappear
or to hand the credit to somebody else
is going to be a lot harder to do.
Is that going to happen? Did you find it?
Do your guardian you've been played?
I love when they use like
contemporary salon. Sketchy.
It's so good. So bitchy. Yeah. You
love say bitchy when it's a girl.
What girl writes it? Um, I don't,
I don't care. I think, I mean,
look, it's only like the future of,
of a number of people been
privately asking me about
the recent guardian article
and accompanying op ed by Oxford
mathematician, Marcos du Sautoy.
How'd he say it? So to Marcus
DeSoto, DeSoto toy gushing over,
suppose supposedly revolutionary.
You knew unified theory of physics by
a man who officially left academia 20
years ago,
or as I've taken to calling it the Eric
Weinstein's amazing new theory that
solves everything.
Puzzling conundrum in theoretical physics
only he hasn't written and actual,
all these are capital letters.
That's why I'm saying it this way,
the letters and actual paper yet.
So physicists can't check all those
hard mathematical details, but trust us,
it's going to be awesome. Wow. That's
super bitchy at him. Wow. Yeah.
I can say that. I can say whatever
the fuck I want. A ham with a period.
First. A couple of caveats. I've
met Weinstein. He's a nice guy.
He's wicked smart. This is a stupid
article cause you know better.
Well, it's just the way it's written.
It's just, it's a catty yeah,
it's for clear clearly. Yeah. Okay.
But we could go deep. She's playing,
she's playing enforcer. Yes.
You broke the rules. Yes. We
know why you broke the rules.
There's fame and fortune for you
in, I think that's what it is. Yeah.
Well or you're delusional or what's
her motivation for writing this article
though? That's what's weird. Well,
she, she's a physics look, she,
she comes from, um, I think she's
approached protege of Casey Cole,
the great physics writer from who's
not a physicist in her defense. Yeah.
Do you feel that she felt this honestly
and that this was problematic and in her
eyes that you were entering into this
field that you had not written a paper and
you had left academia 20 years ago
and that she was like, well, listen,
this is all nonsense. Okay,
I'm going to put a stop to this nonsense
and I'm going to do it with sort of
contemporary language and, and slang.
I don't like the bitchiness but it's,
I understand the motivation.
[inaudible] look,
I think the bitchiness is to make the
article more entertaining and more,
um, it's part of the horrible part
of her style as a writer. Okay.
Now I actually met her as she says, and I,
I had a very high and
positive impression of her.
So why do you think she wrote this
without discussing it? You know, look,
Sean is also one of these people
who's trying to enforce the rules.
He didn't have the easiest time. I
think he didn't get tenure at Cal tech.
He's kind of a stickler for reality.
He's on the one hand
talking total nonsense about
Boltzmann brains and thought
experiments, which is what I
associate with desperation physics.
On the other hand, he's
kind of this rigorous, um,
rationalist thinker who's in,
you know, a prominent atheist.
So he's a complicated guy.
He's a great explainer. Uh,
he's got his own sort of economic
incentives that he's one of the very few
people who sort of a voice, a physics
to the world and they, you know,
operate in some sense as a couple.
And there's a richness to
this. Like, you know, my,
my point isn't to run them
down or to boost them up.
It's just people are
playing at their roles.
Whenever anyone has a sentence
that consists of one word
and that word is a ham.
Yeah, it's, I did not enjoy that
article by him. Well, but look,
yeah, but she's trying to throw me a
bone. He's wicked smart. He's a nice guy,
buddies, but he's
delusional. He's delusional.
And to the extent that I've
been delusional before,
I'm about the only person in the U S
who's against high skilled immigration
because people think, why should we
keep out the best in the brightest?
And it's complicated story. Before
the financial crisis, I was saying,
mortgage backed securities may
blow up the world. People are like,
are you kidding? It's the great
moderation. We've banished volatility.
People have a chance to know me now.
They know that I can get way out there.
I said this at the beginning. I
get way out there. Yeah, okay.
I think Elon Musk Musk is totally
wrong about going to Mars.
Mars is not going to save us and maybe
going to the stars isn't gonna same as
maybe the AI will follow
us there, yada, yada, yada,
but I'm not going to take this lying down.
We're in a desperate situation and if
you're not trying, here's the, here's the,
here's the clear thing.
We know what nuclear weapons
look like in the fusion here.
If we are trying to get off this planet
before people are unleashing gene drives
and you know,
weaponized anthrax and who knows what
the hell people are going to get up to as
the power of biology and the power of
physics keeps going in the power of
information.
All right.
At least I'm trying. I think I'm
doing a damn sight better than trying,
but assume that I failed completely.
How crazy is it that we're not trying to
take arm or arms against our new sea of
troubles? It's time to rush the cockpit.
We've got to get Trump out of office.
We've got to restore sanity to our
sensemaking. We need newspapers,
we need fact checkers.
We did what is particularly problematic
about Trump being in office.
That man has nuclear capabilities and
I have zero confidence in his decision
making and people imagine that I'm a
Trump supporter after I've called him an
existential risk, you know, and my,
my boss and good friend Peter teal
was a supporter of Trump in the last
election. I'm taking a huge risk
and how much I love this guy,
Peter teal and how much he loves me. Uh,
because I'm putting the employer employee
relationship at risk. And people say,
okay, you're just a Peter teal tool. Well,
nobody's gonna take that kind of risk
unless they have real faith in their
friend. And I work for a friend,
I mean a real friend person who doesn't
cut and run when trouble starts.
And I totally disagree with Peter. Uh,
I have come to understand that Trump,
I thought people would understand the
Trump danger and that the democratic party
would reevaluate their
situation, but they didn't.
They tripled and quadrupled
down. And that is alarming.
And so that's something I very much got
wrong about Trump is that even Trump
wasn't enough of a message
to let people know.
But Trump cannot have
the nuclear codes. Um,
because he's not as skilled
or regular enough player.
He's going to accomplish a lot.
One of the things I said before the
election is he might be the best and worst
of presidents.
He might get us a new North Korea deal
because they're going to look at him and
say, this guy is nuts. Who
knows what he would do.
But we, we,
the technical community created this
problem and we're abdicating our
responsibility by worrying about our
egos, by worrying about our reputations.
I am abdicating.
I should've turned this theory over to
the theoretical physics community years
ago.
Even if they screwed me over and I'm too
petty and egotistical to want to give
up on it, I watched them take credit
for things that weren't, you know,
an assigned credit. I don't
like the way they work.
I have the theoretical physics community
is our most important community in the
world and it is also a very unpleasant
community and we need to fund them and we
need to let them play. They're
dangerous boys for the most part.
There are women, but in general,
they're very unpleasant men. Um,
they have been somewhat cowed.
They are not the same Cowboys they used
to be because they'd been failing for 40
years. I should be sharing stuff.
I should be writing things down.
I have not had the courage to do it.
And if I really have the
courage of my convictions,
I should share this and see
what happens. But one thing is,
I don't know if it could be weaponized.
Assume it's right. You know,
I have at this decision tree, so it's
wrong. I've got egg on my face. It's okay.
I'll be okay. I worry much
more about if it's right.
The two things that can
go wrong, if it's right,
is one that could be weaponized
before it becomes useful, and two,
is that there's solution than it may
be. We actually are stuck in this place.
We never get to go to the stars. We
can look at exoplanets and dream,
but we're stuck here.
[inaudible].